bonjour bassem deuxième journée donc de
la conférence de munich emmanuel macron
et sergueï lavrov le chef de la
diplomatie russe doivent s'exprimer
aujourd'hui effectivement c'est au tour
de sergueï lavrov avait des manuels
macron de profiter de la tribune de
cette conférence soit sécurité de munich
la capitale bavaroise continue
d'accueillir l'éditeur politiques du
monde entier depuis hier déjà vous
l'avez dit 500 personnalités du monde de
la défense de la sécurité mais aussi des
membres de la société civile ou des
spécialistes du renseignement et de
l'économie tous réunis pour discuter des
nouvelles stratégies et des nouvelles
relations économiques diplomatiques et
politiques en occident et bien sûr avec
le reste de leurs partenaires mondiaux
emmanuel macron est arrivé hier en a
profité pour dîner avec deux députés des
verts pour revenir un petit peu sur sa
vision de l'europe et surtout pour
revenir sur sa stratégie de défense et
de dissuasion c'est ce qui va essayer de
défendre aujourd'hui les conservateurs
allemands eux sont beaucoup plus
réticents contre cette politique et
emmanuel macron il espérait que que
l'arsenal nucléaire française soit sous
contrôle de l'union européenne et de
l'otan depuis que la grande bretagne
assure à quitter l'union européenne la
france se retrouve seul à détenir cette
arme nucléaire emmanuel macron va
essayer de défendre aujourd'hui grâce à
cette tribune sa position la position de
la france mais surtout sa vision de
l'europe et sa vision de la défense
sergueï lavrov le ministre des affaires
étrangères russe va également profiter
de cette tribune pour pouvoir nous
adresser un panel de professionnels de
politique et de diplomates pour défendre
la vision russe pour essayer d'améliorer
les relations entre la russie et l'union
européenne les américains également
seront sur place sergueï lavrov devrait
normalement s'entretenir avec mike
pompéo ce sera à huis clos ma compo qui
prendra également la parole pour
défendre la politique de donald trump
face à une union européenne qui est de
plus en plus réticente face à la
politique de donald trump les américains
faut savoir sont venus en nombre cette
année nancy pelosi est intervenu hier
énormément de parlementaires américains
le secrétaire de la défense également
américains sont sur place voilà en gros
le programme de cette journée ce qui est
le plus attendu bien sûr c'est emmanuel
macron et sergueï lavrov pour ces
discussions autour des thématiques de la
défense et bien sûr y reviendrons
sur le cas de la libye sur les relations
avec la russie et bien sûr sur cette
course à l'armement que le président
allemand a décliné hier en ouverture de
cette conférence de munich
merci à ben hassen chébili en direct
donc de munich